enough is enough of this garbage they
spread all these lies about the vaccine
how it creates other types of diseases
it's a complete [ __ ] lunacy
and then you take one step off the
another step off the [ __ ] diving
board into this computer ship tracking
device [ __ ]
that's in this goddamn vaccine that
somehow bill gates
created coronavirus to make sure the
vaccine so he could track you
and you're posting this [ __ ] that
there's a computer
chip on facebook while you're on your
phone
with a [ __ ] computer chip in it
this is not rocket science people you're
already being
tracked the government gives you your
social security number you have a
driver's license number
you have an ip address on your phone on
your tablet on your computer
and you carry around a [ __ ] microchip
every goddamn day with your cell phone
still not out of the woods here
and we need to stop this anti-backs
[ __ ]
people standing in front of a goddamn
stadium where they're trying to
vaccinate a large part of the population
for their choice it's their choice to
get vaccinated
so you [ __ ] anti-backs are
anti-mask oh it's my body my choice
[ __ ] about the mask stand the [ __ ] back
out of the way
and let people who want to make the
choice to get the vaccine and help their
community to get
safe so we can open up and get back to
some sort of [ __ ] normal here by
spring or summer
get the hell out of the goddamn way and
shut your [ __ ] mouse
it's possibly disturbed she's carrying
around a cardboard cutout
of donald trump to her campaign events
that's how she was running you [ __ ]
kidding me
full-on cult member cultist
cult 45 and he loves it
well mitch mcconnell doesn't and mitch
mcconnell was the one that gave
permission to the democrats
to remove her from her committee
assignments because kevin mccarthy
wouldn't do it
and if you don't if you don't see who's
actually winning
in these institutions of who's going to
be the republican party leader then
you're not paying attention
because yesterday yesterday
there was a big push to get rid of liz
cheney well they had
they had a secret ballot
that way no one knew who voted it for
and who voted she is not the problem
and i've said this several times she is
only a symptom
of the problem because
if the house were to actually expel this
lady
if they were to remove her from congress
like they removed her from her committee
assignments today
all that would do is allow the
republicans in georgia
to pick her q anon replacement
and we have another whack-a-doo in
congress
that would probably keep their [ __ ]
mouth shut just long enough to get on
the education committee and stay there
and actually have the ability to
possibly do some damage to our country
kicked out of her committee assignments
she says the words that
that the the things that she said those
words are in the past
well of course they're in the past you
[ __ ] [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
all words are in the past all of them
the words i'm saying right now they're
now in the past
there are no words in the future
otherwise they
wouldn't be words yet do these people
even
have a [ __ ] filter before they say
these stupid [ __ ] things
it ain't no wonder this lady believes in
jewish space lasers and
false flag school shootings it is not
it is not that hard to understand why
she believes this dumb [ __ ]
if she says something like that that
those words are in the past
cannot sell a cheeseburger for any more
than what that cheeseburger is
worth okay and frankly
mcdonald's and any other outfit whether
it's wendy's or applebee's or whoever
is gonna sell hamburgers for the for the
price that is going to make them the
most
profit and that doesn't always mean it's
going to be the most expensive
that's not what it means i mean a lot of
people fail to remember in business
models there's lost leaders
here i mean if you guys remember the the
mcdonald's dollar menu
you really think when they had dollar
cheeseburgers on the mcdonald's menu
that that that was the highest price
that they could actually
charge for mcdonald's cheeseburger at
that time hell to the no
that is not the thing that happened they
were trying to get your fat ass through
the drive-through
and buying dollar cheeseburgers and then
maybe you'll add on a large fry and a
large coat donald trump did not think it
was a good idea
to use the argument uh this q
anon argument uh because that's what was
going to happen here folks
that this q anon [ __ ] was going to leak
into this trial
so they all quit they tell him to go
[ __ ] himself
which is basically what happens in
donald trump's life because he's not a
serious person
i mean that's why we have these marjorie
taylor greens and lauren boberts and mo
brooks these are not serious [ __ ]
people
and the reason why we have these people
in the house and some of them in the
senate is because
donald trump a a not so serious person
at all became the president of the
united states so it was easy for
for councilman and state legislators and
governors and
and congress people and senators to
become [ __ ]
elected officials when they're not so
[ __ ] serious as well
wants his defense to be about voter
fraud he wants to continue and
perpetuate the
this lie about voter fraud
on the floor of the united states senate
inside the impeachment trial which is
not a good idea
it really is not a good idea to go and
lie
on the senate floor it's not going to
work very well
and the reason why is because you're
going to get some of these senators
that are not going to vote with marjorie
taylor green
types if you get catch my drift here
i mean why do you think the democrats
are trying to make marjorie taylor green
the face of the party
is because they're gonna make [ __ ]
republican
sentence vote either for
that type of thought and that type of
[ __ ]
or reality [ __ ] that's real facts
you're going to have to decide you're
gonna have to make a [ __ ] real choice
has been so successful at fox news is
because they've known that their policy
ideas
are [ __ ] horrible and they know that
their policy ideas do not help the
majority of people in this country
they don't and that's why
they have to sell lies they have to sell
propaganda they have to spin this and do
uh you know they spend it in a hundred
different directions any direction they
can at any point
but right now it's it's in the way of
maga make america great again you know
they
they they they did the whole birther
thing while obama was president
and then uh when when uh when trump and
hillary ran against each other it was
all about her [ __ ] emails i mean
jesus christ they still talk about her
[ __ ] emails on fox news
and it's been five goddamn years almost
now now it's complete
front to back voter fraud
that didn't that doesn't pillow nazi you
know the mypillow guy
he gets on newsmax and they're trying to
talk to him about being canceled on
twitter because they permanently banned
his twitter account
and then he decides it's a good [ __ ]
idea to go tweet on the mypillow account
and they [ __ ] ban that account too
they're like you're done [ __ ]
we told you to stay off twitter you'd
stay off our platform you mustache
mussolini
so they cancel him and they have him on
newsmax
to talk about how he was canceled on
twitter and he starts bringing up
dominion voting machines and if you
don't know oan and newsmax and fox news
are going to be wrapped up in these
multi-billion dollar
uh lawsuits these libel lawsuits that
that dominion has against them
and there has to be some some good cause
for this and the reason why is because
if you watch this interview
you'll see that they are absolutely
[ __ ] take hair if you don't take this
marjorie taylor green
off committee assignments we will we
will do it and then she threatens
oh if you do that ooh watch out when we
win in 2022.
well you have to [ __ ] win something
here before you
before you can say oh we'll take
democrats out of committee assignments
and i don't think people understand um
just how effective taking a congress
person's committee assignments away from
them
actually is it is a big deal
you get elected to congress to have
committee assignments
like that's the whole [ __ ] point
the whole point there's not a lot of
[ __ ] you can do
for your constituency if you do not have
a committee assignment
there's not a lot of stuff you can trade
away to other members
and their committees this stuff will
handicap her pretty damn fast
here mitch mcconnell is trying to to
support liz cheney and give her room
uh to possibly become the minority
leader in the house as opposed to be
ousted
uh the second in charge steve scalise
is is uh not i can't decide which side
he's on does do he
does he want to keep his crazy
constituents happy does he want to keep
the q and honors on his side
the vote the q and on voters or does he
want to go back to the old gop
john dune john thune has the nerve to
say today
that the gop has to decide it has to
decide whether it wants to be
the party of small government physical
responsibility
pro-life freedom with power
for power or does it want to be
the party of q anon conspiracy theories
well you [ __ ] done sold that
out